que se sabe hasta ahora de la retirada
de serena williams está confirmada
pues muy buenas tardes a todos realmente
ella hizo un anuncio que se iba a
retirar sin embargo pues estaba una
expectativa yo creo que ayer los gestos
de emoción todo el público
ovacionando la no sólo los que
estuvieron presentes en la cancha sino
en el mundo por el seguimiento digamos
de este partido que fue espectacular yo
creería que sí ya definitivamente se va
a retirar y se retira por la puerta
grande muchos de pronto piensan que
porque perdió en tres en tercera ronda
de pronto no salió por la puerta grande
pero 23 grand slam yo creo que son
suficientes para hacer la mejor tenista
de la historia no sólo en el ámbito
femenino sino también en el masculino
sólo se habla de los hombres pero para
mí es la mejor tenista de la historia
porque guau guau qué logros y qué mujer
de verdad que también ha apoyado mucho
la equidad de género en el deporte y en
el tenis femenino
precisamente mariana para los menos
ilustrados
deporte explíquenos por qué es
considerada una estrella incomparable
del tenis bueno son 23 grandes lado los
que ganó serena williams les sigue
rafael nadal con 22 después djokovic con
21 y cr con 20 eso demuestra que ha sido
la tenista más grande de la historia en
el ámbito femenino masculino y se va una
de las grandes y yo creo que voy a dejar
un hueco muy importante en el deporte y
en el deporte femenino porque lo que
jalaba en términos de audiencia de
patrocinios es muy importante y creo que
el tenis se va a demorar mucho tiempo y
sobre todo el tenis femenino pero una
estrella de esa magnitud y claro
precisamente como decía no jalaba
muchísima audiencia y luchó usted lo
decía mucho por la equidad en el deporte
precisamente para usted y para otras a
tenistas colombianas o de alrededor del
mundo qué significa esta figura como las
ha influenciado en su carrera
pues yo creo que mucho mucho porque
siempre luchó por por los por las bolsas
de premios equitativas para hombres y
mujeres vemos que en todos los deportes
la diferencia salarial es impresionante
y ella en su lucha logró mermar un poco
esa gran brecha que hay en el tenis
femenino con el tenis masculino así que
el legado es muy grande más allá de los
triunfos
a nivel deportivo y yo creo que esa es
una de las grandes labores y misiones
que deben tener los deportistas más allá
del aspecto deportivo sino ser grandes
seres humanos dejar un legado importante
y creo que ese es uno de los grandes
legados que deja serena williams